what's going on
i'm not i'm not doing [ __ ] i'm not
doing this i watch you no no they're
breaking the law man they're breaking
the [ __ ] out here who's breaking the law
away from this i'm running the law
breaking the law man you don't back up
back up back up don't get physical
back up back up man you're a gold digger
all you want is some money you don't
want no relationships do you know him no
exactly you don't know me all right
let's just back up if i was john cena i
bet you you're
if i was during the rock justin
nobody wants to [ __ ] here man you might
want
don't touch me bro get out of here leave
me alone get out here leave the woman
alone
you touch me i'ma crush you bro you're
going to curse me now no witchcraft okay
that's fine don't touch me bro well i'm
not going to touch you but you don't
know witchcraft fool i understand i'm
going to crush you and your firstborn
son you touch me okay all right well i
don't want that that number my firstborn
son but you know if you have you have to
do what you have to do